and then the worst snake of all is
malevolence and that's I think that's
technically correct because one of the
things that you view for example when
you're looking at post-traumatic stress
disorder is that it's almost always the
case that someone who suffers from
post-traumatic stress disorder which you
might think of as a real real-life
reincarnation of the fall is that people
encounter something malevolent and it
breaks them because it's the worst thing
to understand
it's like suffering is one thing man
that's that's bad now vulnerability and
suffering that's bad enough but to
encounter someone who wishes that upon
you and will work to bring it about
that's a whole different category of
horrible especially what it also
reflects something back to you about
yourself because if someone else can do
that to you
and they're human that means that you
partake of the same essence strangely
enough that's actually the cure to some
degree to post-traumatic stress disorder
is it like if you've been victimized
you're naive and you've been victimized
the way out of that is to no longer be
naive and to no longer be victimized and
that means that you you see this
reflected in the Harry Potter idea for
example that the reason that Harry
Potter can withstand Voldemort is
because he's got a piece of a right he's
being touched by it and the way that you
the way that you keep the psychopaths at
bay is to develop the inner psychopath
so that you know one when you see one
right and then but that's a voluntary
thing it's it's so it's like a it's like
a a set of tools that you have at your
disposal which is full knowledge of evil
and that does Nietzsche said if you look
into an abyss for too long you risk
having the abyss gaze back into you
right the idea is that if you look at
something monstrous you have a tendency
to turn into a monster and people are
often very afraid of looking at
monstrous things exactly for that reason
and then the question is well should you
turn into a monster and the answer to
that is yes you should but you should do
it voluntarily and not accidentally and
you should do it with the good in mind
rather than falling prey to it by
possession essentially because that's
the alternative how does it possess you
that's easy
you're suffering makes you better you're
better this makes you resentful you
resent
means meat makes you vengeful and once
you're on that road you go down that a
little bit farther man well you end up
it fantasizing in your basement about
shooting up the local high school and
then killing yourself right because
that's sort of the ultimate end of that
line of pathological reasoning being
should be eradicated because of its
intrinsic evil and I'm exactly the
person to do it and I'll cap it off with
an indication of my own lack of worth
just to hammer the point home right and
if I can garner a little post post
posthumous fame along the way well
that'll satisfy my primordial primate
dominance hierarchy imaginings too at
least in fantasy so you know it's the
full package if you want to go down that
route and of course people don't like to
think about that sort of thing and it's
no bloody wonder but without the
capability for mayhem Europe you're
you're you're a potential victim to may
have so you need your sword it should be
sheath but you need to have it and it's
very frequently the case if you treat
someone with post-traumatic stress
disorder there's two things you have to
do you have to help them develop a very
articulated philosophy of evil because
otherwise their brain bothers them over
and over and over what why were you so
dealing with naive how did you become
victimized why were you such a sucker
these are good questions you don't want
to have that happen to you again you
don't want to be exploited twice okay so
your eyes have to open up we know the
price of that from the Egyptian myth
right you come into contact with Seth
what happens even if you're a god you
lose an eye it's no joke man
it's no joke and then the cure for that
is the movement down into the underworld
and with the revitalization of the
Father
that's the identification with the force
that created culture right and that then
there's you and that together then you
can withstand malevolence maybe you can
withstand tragedy and malevolence and
then that's the whole secret right
because that's what you want in life you
need to be able to withstand tragedy and
you need to be able to withstand
malevolence because those are the forces
they're always working against you and
so it's just this is associated with the
Union idea of incorporation of the
shadow right you have to be we know this
God we know how predators work with
regards to children even if you're a
pedophilic predator
and you're looking at a landscape of
children the child that you're going to
go after is the one that's timid and
won't fight back you pick your victim
and predatory people in general are
exactly like that man they're because
they're predators they're not going to
attack someone who's who's going to
fight back
in fact the issue is likely not to even
come up they're going to be looking for
someone one way or another that cannot
conceptualize what they are and then
perfect it's it's open season and it's
open season and so if you're treating
someone with post-traumatic stress
disorder first they need an introduction
to the philosophy of malevolence and
second they have to learn to become
dangerous because that's the only way
out what's the alternative to get these
recurrent thoughts about their
vulnerability in the face of malevolence
and their own naivety because by
definition if someone psychopathic has
exploited you you're too naive it's a
definitional issue you can say well
that's no fault of mine how the hell
could I be prepared fair not man a
perfectly reasonable objection doesn't
solve your problem because it's an it's
an eternal problem